now water and sewage firms in England
have issued a public apology for not
acting quickly enough on sewage spills
according to the environment agency
untreated sewage was pumped into
England's rivers and seized more than
300 000 times last year an average of
824 per day with the industry body water
UK has today promised to spend 10
billion pounds on what it claims will be
the biggest modernization of the sewers
since the Victorian era or joining me
now is the chair of water UK the former
cabinet minister Ruth Kelly Ruth Kelly
welcome to you this has been known about
for years why has it taken so long for
the industry to apologize
yeah thank you thank you very much for
inviting me here today it's good to be
on and let's take a step back the first
thing I'm here to do today is to say
sorry
I've been very chastened by listening to
the public by hearing the views of
people I understand we understand it's a
water industry how upset and angry
people are about untreated sewage going
into rivers and onto our beaches and we
are determined to put that right so
today we're announcing a tripling of the
level of investment into tackling spills
into rivers and onto beaches and you're
right to say why has it taken us so long
we we get it we should have acted sooner
it's only in the last few years in fact
and that we've had the data to really
see the extent of this problem but we
are absolutely determined now to put
that right
is this new money this 10 billion pounds
or is this money that the industry would
have had to have put up anyway given
that the government announced a storm
overflows reduction uh scheme in August
last year
this is new money that goes on top of
the three billion that's already been
pledged to tackle this issue this is
money which of course will feed through
to the government's overall Target we
want to go as fast as we possibly can to
try and reduce the number of spills
however we think that 10 billion pounds
in a five-year period is the maximum
physical capacity of the sector to make
these changes so you're talking about
hiring construction
experts you're talking about scientists
you're talking about engineers being
employed to build huge big sewage
overflow tanks the size of Olympic
swimming pools thousands of these
underground across the country so we
don't think we can do it faster than
this but we're determined to make every
effort we can to stop putting this
problem right and where's the money
going to come from shareholders or
customers
well what we're doing is we're asking
shareholders to to put down a huge down
payment multi-billion pound down payment
uh to start putting this problem right
it's the biggest transformation project
in the water industry's history since
the Victorian times the way the system
works is that over the lifetime of the
asset customers do pay that money back
in in modest increases in their bills
over the last 10 years I think it's
important to remember that that real
water bills have fallen for the average
customer and our research shows us that
customers of the whole are prepared to
pay a little bit more to see this in
source of investment undertaken but
customers will be asking why on Earth
should they be having to put their hand
in their pocket when the water industry
paid out 1.4 billion pounds in dividends
last year
well I think as a sign of the
seriousness with which the water
companies are taking at this issue and
all water companies CEOs have have come
together and they've said they're not
going to pay a single penny for instance
on bonuses out of customer funds this
year half of them the water and sewage
companies across England and Wales are
waving their bonus entirely on dividends
I don't quite recognize the the picture
that you're painting on dividends last
year three of the of the 10 water and
sewage companies uh actually made a loss
and the average return across the sector
was less than less than four percent now
that's not that much more than you'd get
if you if they just put it in Bank in
the bank on on deposit so so we do need
to attract hundreds of billions of
investment over the coming decades into
the sector we have to compete against
other utility companies the energy
companies the airports the rail sector
we have to compete for this money so
it's right that at dividend ought to be
paid but as I say the dividends have
been at fairly low levels compared to
other sectors even after this investment
sewage spills may still be in the 100
thousands I mean why is it ever
acceptable for untreated sewage to enter
waterways
yeah I mean it's right it's a it's a
really horrible relic of the past to see
untreated sewage um go into into the
waterways you never would have built a
system from scratch today uh in in that
way
um it's you know hard to understand why
why water from bathrooms and kitchens is
mingled with with fresh groundwater and
rain water and all treated together you
wouldn't design a system like that but
that is the system we've got
and it is going to take time to put that
right now even with billions of pounds
of investment if you look at the London
super uh sewer as an example four
billion pounds just just putting into
the Thames Water Area to treat uh to
treat London's sewage that doesn't
eliminate leaks spills completely but
they do become extremely limited
um and you know the the harm that it's
caused is is completely eliminated so um
we won't get to a situation where
they're all disappear disappear but we
are all going to make a dramatic impact
on the harm caused by spills
presumably uh this investment is not
going to be equally spread across the
country I mean somewhere like United
Utilities in the Northwest I mean their
sewage spill level is about four or five
times the rate of somewhere like
Southern water in the south of England
yeah you're right the infrastructure is
different in different parts of the
country and more work needs to be done
in some areas than others as a water
sector we're saying holders to account
for the Investments that we make and we
want to do this in in two ways first by
publishing a detailed investment plan
there are 15
000 over spills in this country
overflows that lead to spills we want to
publish an investment plan which spill
overflow spill by overflow spill says
exactly what's going to happen when the
money is going to be invested and what
the result of that is going to be so
that people will be able to see that
secondly by this time next year we're
saying to people you know log on we're
going to have a single Central data Hub
you can log on you can you can check to
for your locality see exactly if any
discharges have been made what
discharges have been made and decide uh
whether you want to go bathing at that
time so real accountability and
transparency around the level of
discharges across the country
parting uh thought from me if you would
please I mean water privatization has
led to 160 billion pounds worth of
investment as she said water bills are
far lower in the UK or in England and
Wales than they are in countries where
the state operates the water system why
is it do you think so many people favor
renationalization
well sometimes I think renationalization
is seen as free money but obviously it's
it's not and I mean I've sat in the
treasury as a treasury Minister and I've
sat on the other side of the table as
well where people come to bids for
investment and I know how difficult it
would be under a nationalized sector uh
for for to to really get the investment
that's so desperately needed when you're
competing against investment in
hospitals and in schools so it's not a
you know a uh a free win scenario as it
were being being nationalized that money
has to come from somewhere and what
we're saying is that shareholders stand
ready to invest hundreds of billions of
pounds in the water sector to to really
improve it
all right Ruth Kelly gotta leave it
there good to see you this morning thank
you